There are five keys to building rock-solid partnerships.
The first is how you get in the door.
Make sure you get a warm intro.
Use your network and get somebody to link you into that person.
It builds a nice common ground to start the partnership.
The second is know their business.
You want to know the business or the partner that you're going into...
...almost as much as you know your own business...
...and that segues in to understand their needs.
You really want to understand what their needs are...
...just as much as you understand your needs...
...so that you can negotiate the best possible deal.
The fourth is really solving their pain-point.
Once you understand their needs, you can really better quantify, clarify,...
...and communicate how you can solve their pain-point.
And the last is you're cultivating a long-term relationship when you're building a partnership,...
...so this is not a deal that you close and that you move on.
You need to cultivate this relationship for the long term,...
...which includes the small things like holiday cards,...
...but also keeping up with where that company is and sending notes on important events...
...like financing or other partnerships that they've entered into.
If you stick with these five core tips,...
...you will be on your way to building great rock-solid partnerships.